[Music]
6
26 on your friday morning we're hitting
the trail where the 95 meets the 215
northern beltway come on let's go
centennial bowling
so last week we talked about the three
new centennial bull freeway connections
as well as the east west non-freeway
connections between oso blanca and sky
point
well to make those happen osoblanca is
going to be
realigned and widened eventually
connecting further south to centennial
center
on the east side of the 95 sky point is
going to be relocated and widened
it will connect centennial parkway to
azure drive
now about that new multi-use trail it's
not going to be just around centennial
parkway and sky point it's actually
going to stretch all the way from
grand montecito on the west to tanea on
the east and will include
several new miles of bike lanes and
sidewalks
as we mentioned last week this 155
million dollar final phase
of the centennial ball project it kicked
off the first of the month scheduled to
take
three years to complete we've got all
this up on our website eightnewsnow.com
click traffic than driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com